uh astute observers may recognize that i
am not in fact jared lander
i'm max [ __ ] and i'm here to introduce
him so jared
is the chief data scientist at later
analytics he's also the organizer of the
new york open statistical
programming meetup and also the
organizer of new york r and
uh dcr conferences he's a junk professor
at columbia and that's where he got his
degree in statistics
he's also the author of r for everyone
and he's going to give a talk on
comparing tree based models so welcome
jared
a couple years ago at the dc conference
i gave a talk about many ways to fit
lasso regressions
so now we turn our attention to decision
trees there are
so many types of trees and we're going
to talk about a lot of them
we will go over a little bit of math
we'll see how to train the models
compare their speed check their accuracy
visualize the trees and see a unified
interface for all of them
first the data
this is credit data it has a binary
outcome variable
because 90 of the time when people talk
about ml
they think of binary classification
decision trees can also do
numeric outcome variables poisson
variables for account data
survival models multi-class
classification and other types
but we are going to focus on binary
outcomes today
and the inputs can be either numeric or
qualitative
this data set is imbalanced and it would
be better for classification if it were
balanced
so we go to the recipes and themis
packages
to up sample the data we are also going
to
make sure that the categorical variables
are not factors because strings as
factors equals true
is the default for this package like
we've learned nothing from base r
so now the data are balanced
we will look at single trees to begin
in this simplified case we have two
numeric inputs
and a binary outcome and the idea is
that we want to
break up this data space into
homogeneous regions
or at least as homogeneous as they can
get we want any one region to be
as uniform as possible then
when you get a new data point you find
which region that data point begins in
and then for the two class
classification problem
you take majority rules so it's the
percentage of the largest majority
becomes the prediction this generalizes
to
the multi-class case
if it's a regression problem you still
break the data space up into regions
you get a new data point you find which
region it belongs to
then the prediction is the average of
that region
our part was one of the first packages
for fitting decision trees
and it stands for recursive partitioning
because you are continuing
you you are continuously breaking up the
data space
this can fit regression models
classification poisson and survival
models
now it only has a formula interface
categorical inputs can be either
characters or factors
and a categorical outcome can be
character a factor as well
and this handles missing data for us
you call the model with outcome tilde
inputs and in this case the dot stands
for
all the other variables are the inputs
you can plot this with our part dot plot
and this is
this is where we can see it gets the
name decision tree because
as you as you ask a series of questions
it creates a branching pattern
it's very easy to understand for simple
trees
a nice thing about trees is that
variables get used repeatedly
so you can make a variable importance
plot in this case it is the sum of the
goodness of split for each time the
variable was used
there are a few tuning parameters
perhaps the most important is max
depth the maximum number of splits for
terminal nodes
it's how deep and complex a tree can get
but why fit one tree when you can fit
hundreds of trees
leo breiman and adele cutler came up
with the idea to take
b bootstrap samples of the data and
fitting an independent tree to each
sample this is bootstrap aggregating
or bagging so that's the first level of
randomness
repeatedly sampling the data but there's
another level when you're fitting a
decision tree you have to decide where
to split the data
and you would consider all the variables
in a random forest
each time you would split each tree you
randomly sample the columns that you'll
consider
and then judge those which one should be
the splitting column
so there are two levels of randomness
the random forest package is aptly named
and is a wrapper around leo bryan's
fortran code
this can do both regression and
classification and it has a formula
interface
and an xy interface if you're using the
formula interface you have to be careful
that categorical variables are stored as
factors
if you're using the xy interface the
input matrix must be dense
and this does not handle missing data
so we go back to recipes and we do k n
imputation on any missing data
and we make sure that all of our
categorical variables are factors
we fit the model using the formula and
it might look like just another formula
but we had to be careful that
categorical variables were stored as
factors
if you plot the model it shows you the
error rate as a function of the number
of trees
we can see that there is a quick drop
off but it very quickly after that
levels off and doesn't improve much by
adding more trees
the variable importance is how much each
variable contributes to increases in
accuracy
now random forests aren't supposed to
need to tuning
yet here we are there are a number of
tuning parameters
perhaps the most important are entry the
number of trees to grow
and sample size how large of a sample to
draw for each round
ranger sort of like a forest ranger
is an alternative to random forest
written in c plus
this can do regression classification
and survival models
and in the formula interface categorical
inputs can be either character or factor
but a categorical outcome must be a
factor
if you use the xy interface you could
use either denser sparse matrices
and another nice interface is you can
provide a data frame
then tell it the column that stands for
the outcome variable
this also does not handle missing data
so we use the same
imputed data frame we used earlier and
we call ranger using the formula
and in order to get a variable
importance plot later we set
importance equals impurity
calling plot on ranger returns an error
because there's no
plot method defined for it so this is an
expected error
luckily we can still get a variable
importance plot and this is how much
each variable contributes to increases
in accuracy
there are a number of tuning parameters
including num trees and max depth like
we've seen before
and also regularization factors as a way
of penalizing the model for
overcomplication
but instead of fitting individual trees
we can stack the trees by boosting
now boosting works of any type of
machine learning but it's mostly done on
trees
the idea is that you fit a model then
the next model
uses the first model's residuals as the
outcome variable
and each subsequent model uses the prior
model's residuals as the outcome
this allows the tree to get smarter and
smarter each time it's fit
the idea is that you stack a bunch of
weak learners like a bunch of stumpy
trees
gbm is the original gradient boosted
machine
it can do regression classification
poisson survival and ranking
now it mostly has a formula interface
it's possible to use x
y using a different function though
categorical inputs must be a factor
and a binary outcome variable must be 0
1 and it does handle missing data for us
so we use a recipe to make sure that
status is
0 1 and that all of our other
categoricals are
factors we then fit the model using a
formula
and we explicitly say that distribution
equals bernoulli
and we say n trees equals a hundred to
do a hundred rounds of boosting
when you call plot on this it creates a
partial dependency plot
now this one might be a little ambitious
trying to show three variables at once
but it's nice that we can and of course
you could show fewer variables
the variable importance is the relative
influence of a variable
in reducing loss
here's the tuning parameters with
entries being the number of boosting
rounds probably being the most important
interaction depth controls complexity
it's how deep a tree can go
and shrinkage it's a way it's the
learning rate
c5 is a nice alternative for boosting
and it can also fit a single tree if you
want to all of these can
now c5 only does classification
if you're using the formula interface
the categorical inputs can be either
character or factor
but if it is a outcome
variable being classification which it
has to be it must be a factor
it also has an x y interface where you
can use dense matrices
and this handles missing data for us and
generates rule-based models
so here we convert status into a factor
in line in the formula
taking advantage of that property of
formulas and we say trials equals 100
for the number of boosting rounds
when you plot it you can choose which
subtree to start plotting at
and this actually gives us a pretty
complicated tree whenever you get to
boosting
it gets very hard to understand your
trees
also the variable importance plot when
you're boosting a c5
it's showing you the percentage of
training samples found in terminal nodes
after the split
but it's not really giving us much
information since they're all at 100.
the main tuning parameter is trials for
the number of boosting rounds
next we get to the master of kaggle
xg boost this can do regression
classification and ranking now it only
takes the xy interface
but you have to feed it into the special
xgb.d matrix object
the x matrix can be either dense or
sparse or even files on disk
for binary classification the outcome
variable must be 0 or 1.
this handles missing values for us it
could even handle imbalanced data for us
and it can also fit glms which is pretty
cool you can fit a
penalized linear regression and it can
be trained on either cpu or a gpu
we use recipes to make sure that our
outcome variable is 0 1
and we convert all the other categorical
variables into dummies
we create our sparse matrix for x and
our dense matrix for y
and we put it into this xgb.d matrix
object
notice the notation they're calling the
input data and the output label
as if regression was an afterthought
then we train the model with xgb.train
they're using this xgb dot notation
because they're trying to emulate a
python
environment so we call xub.train
give it the data we tell the objective
is a binary logistic
we're doing 100 rounds of boosting and
we're printing out the error rate every
10 rounds
while there is no plotting function we
can plot using digraphs
the error rate as a function of the
number of trees and we can see it gets
better and better and better
and since we're not using a validation
set we have to hope it won't overfit
you can use xgb plot multi-trees to try
to plot all the trees into one display
i don't recommend this because this
isn't that useful even for a single tree
variable importance is the fractional
contribution of each feature
to the model based on the total gain of
that feature splits
there are a lot of tuning parameters for
xg boost and you're pretty much
just going to brute force your way
through these turning parameters
the most important are end rounds for
the number for the number of boosting
rounds
eta for the learning rate max depth for
how complicated each tree can get
but you can also combine subsample call
sample by tree
and numb parallel trees to create a
boosted pseudo random forest which is
pretty cool
an alternative to light cheat and
alternative to xg boost is like gbm
now it's not on cran yet but the package
authors i
asked them if they could get it ready
for cram by the time i gave my talk and
they came very very close
so i really want to include it
this can do regression or classification
and it only has an xy interface which
also uses a special object
lgb.dataset the x matrix can be either
dense
or sparse or a file on disk categorical
inputs can be
either dummies or numeric encoding which
is pretty cool
if it's a binary outcome it must be
stored as zero one
this handles missing values for us it
can handle unbalanced data
and it can be trained on a cpu or gpu
so we go to our recipe we make sure all
the categoricals are
stored as integers and then we keep
track of which of the inputs are
categorical
because when we create this lgb.dataset
we pass it our
matrix for x our matrix for y then we
tell it which columns and x
are categorical even though they're
stored as 0 1 2 3 as integers
we then fit the model with light gbm we
pass it the data set
the n rounds for with 100 in this case
the objective is binary and we're going
to evaluate it every 10 rounds
even though our data set was already
balanced i just want to show is
unbalanced equals true will handle
balance for us
there is no plotting method so this
returns an error
and we can calculate the variable
importance using
built-in functions and this is the
percent gain in accuracy
there are a lot more tuning parameters
than i am showing but none
iterations for the number of boosting
rounds the learning rate and the max
depth are going to be the most important
and bagging and feature fraction
controls how much randomness it gets
and you can even set different types of
boosting
there are other models that we didn't
have time to discuss
rule fit fits a boosted tree then
extracts the rules
and takes them in the original
predictors and puts them into a
penalized aggression
boost handles categorical variables
similar similarly to
light gbm and is put up by yandex bart
is a bayesian boosted tree and
tensorflow can fit boosted trees as well
there are so many different interfaces
we need to think about whether we use a
formula or matrices and then are they
dense or sparse or do we use a data
frame
or proprietary formats how do we handle
categorical variables
dummies versus an american coding versus
factors
our part uses a formula c5 uses a
formula of dense matrices
random force can use a formula or dense
matrix but you've got to worry about the
outcome variable
ranger can also do a formula or dense
matrix gbm prefers a formula
xgboost and light gbm need their own
special objects
our part can take categorical variables
as a character or factor
c5 can also do the same or dummy
variables random force can take factors
or dummy variables
rangers can take factors or dummy
variables or characters
gbm can only take factors or dummy
variables xgboost prefers dummy
variables needs dummy variables
and like gbm can take either dummies or
numeric encoding there's a lot to
consider
we really need one standard
carrot used to be my go-to package
but not anymore now i use something tidy
tidy models also written by the author
of carrot
we start with parsnip in order to
specify the type of model
we say we want to fit a decision tree
using our part
or we can fit a decision tree using c5
or if we want to do a random forest we
can say we want to fit a random forest
using the random forest package or
we could fit a random forest using the
ranger package
if we want to boost of trees we just say
boost tree
with the c5 package or
boost the tree with the xg boost package
it's the same exact pattern for every
type of model the
is the type of model you want to fit
then the engine we are not doing like
gbm or gbm because they're not supported
by parsnip
we then do feature engineering of
recipes but
first we split the data into training
and testing like a good data scientist
does
the pre-processing for our part is just
going to be up sampling and then we will
collapse some factor variables
same with c5 or just going to upsample
random force where you're going to up
sample make sure categorical variables
are factors
and we're going to do imputation ranger
is the same thing
c5 for boosting we're just going to up
sample
and xg we are going to upsample and we
are going to convert our categorical
variables into dummy variables
then we use workflows to combine
everything
now i could have just loaded tidy models
but i like loading individual packages
so i know where my functions come from
and for all the model types it's the
same you take workflow
and then you add in a recipe for the
feature engineering and then a model for
the model specification
here it is for the trees for random
forest it's exactly the same
a workflow add a recipe add a model
for boosted trees it's a workflow recipe
model is the same exact thing for all
the steps
it's very common it's very nice easy to
remember this
then we can go ahead and fit the models
and it's the same for all of them
we take our workflow object and we fit
it with the training data
so it when you call fit it does the
pre-processing
and then it trains the model and since
that's the same for the trees the random
force and the boosted trees
you fit the workflow with the training
data that's it
it's the same exact interface for all of
them
so how do we do i want to know our
accuracy
and our speed so i put all the workflows
into a list so that i can iterate over
them
we are going to use this in a little
we then define our quality metric in
this case auc
we then map over that list of workflows
and for each of them
we apply them to we apply them to the
data split object where we
do the pre-processing and the training
on the training data
and then we make predictions on the test
data and see how we did with the quality
metric
this code just mainly goes through and
collects those metrics from each of the
different models we fit
and then we plot the results here we can
see that
our part and c5 did the worst they're
the simplest models
xg boosts random force in ranger the
more complex models did the best
but what good is a complex model if it
takes forever to fit
so we're also interested in how long it
took
so we use the bench package to fit each
model repeatedly
and see how fast they are
and now we see that the simple models c5
and our part were the fastest
but xgboost was right there with them
this complicated model was extremely
fast
whereas the other complicated models
ranger and random forest
were the slowest so what we really want
to look at
is the combination of time and auc we
want to find the pareto optimum
that upper left corner is where we want
to be and xg boost is coming in
at the nice combination of speed and
accuracy
what did we learn
there are so many interfaces to know
there are nuances for each model that we
need to be aware of
and xg boost is nearly the fastest
and nearly the most correct
for this data on my computer
and importantly everything is easier
with tidy models
thank you